it's so wonderful to see both of you
because we have a lot of catching up to
do since the last time we talked and
it's all good news which i think is just
awesome
because it's proven that if you use your
voice change can happen
so congratulations to both of you and
what has happened with soul survivors
and the fact that
cbs initiative is making the cast 50
percent
by pocket i mean how are you feeling and
sitting with that and have you kind of
reflected what this all means
i absolutely applaud cbs for taking our
ideas and listening to our thoughts and
putting them into action
so i really want to say that they chose
to
change with the times a lot of people
are scared
about our country our country is going
through a shift and
we including cbs and survivor need to
change with the time so they chose to be
on the right side of history
i'm very excited about that and i hope
other networks follow their lead
but we will be watching so we will be
watching
wendell i i agree with jatia i am
um pleasantly surprised and impressed
and proud of cbs
um i've i've known survivor to stay with
the times and
to speak to what's going on in the
country and be able to
use their voice for good and i guess
when they heard us speaking up
and when they saw what was going on you
know within the country
post george floyd but it obviously has
been going on forever
when they saw the hurt um in our faces
and heard it in our voices
and when we went to them they were
responsive
they were open to hearing they were open
to being um
they were open to criticisms and they
were looking for solutions
and i think that they did a great job in
in responding and hearing us and
responding to that
and allowing for fifty percent by poc um
going forward it's
it's going to be a beautiful thing so
you sat at the table with cbs and told
them about the petition about soul
survivors
we we had a discussion with them it was
like it was a closed door
kind of meeting but there were there
were a group of us
we sat down with a few people from cbs
including jeff probst
and we let them know you know what's
going on we told them about the petition
and they listened to us and then they
came back to us and said hey look
things will happen and we heard that
and we were just i think we were just
kind of waiting like let's let's see how
this really plays out
and then obviously earlier in this week
we saw all of these
press releases saying that they will
have at least
50 pipe going forward on all the casts
which is
a huge leap in the right direction
obviously there's more work to be done
there are more things
that we're waiting to hear or to that
we're listening for
to see if you know other things maybe
behind the camera or
or in casting if other things change but
this is
this is something that really puts it in
the cast a lot of it in the castaway's
hands now now it's like look
there is uh there's there's great
representation and
now you know let's let's see how this
plays out they also
decided that they were going to fund 25
of their
unscripted reality um production budget
was going to go to
bypoc so that's also another behind the
camera wow
initiative so that is fantastic we are
really excited there were some other
things that were specific to survivor
that
um were explained to us and we were
excited about those so we think
again this is a great first step and we
are definitely going to hold their feet
to the fire and hold them accountable so
and jeff probst i mean wendell last time
you talked we talked you said you wanted
to talk to him have that conversation
with him and that the fact that you did
what was that conversation like and did
you feel that
he was there listening to what you had
to say
i i've always been a big jeff props fan
you know being a fanboy that got on the
show and
was able to win in my first season i've
always been a fan of the guy
and i've i've known him to be a good
person because he fought for me to be on
the show
so fast forward to season 40 when i
wasn't too
happy with how i was being portrayed
i was able to call him and he told me
certain things to like you know kind of
calm me down a little bit
and then i watched it play out more and
i was a little more uneasy
and then getting together with this
collective and having this
this kind of shared experience that many
um
african-americans have on the season as
at
on the on the show as a whole like
we don't necessarily always get the best
edits and right a lot of times we are
of the first few castaways that are
voted out or if
two castaways happen to get two black
castaways having to get together um
they're seen as a huge threat and they
need to be voted out so
um fast forward to me and the rest of us
coming back and talking with jeff again
he he's a listener he wants to do right
so
it's good to talk to him because he has
he wants to be on the right side of
history and in his heart he wants the
right things portrayed
he understands the uh i guess the
magnitude that this
this show the the the the reach that
this show has
and so because of that i think he was
very apt to listening to us
and making the right changes and i mean
like they just released that there will
be fifty percent bipac um within the
last week and yeah
i guess we talked to you what like four
months ago saying yeah
yeah so it's it's been a while and we've
just been waiting and waiting
and you know you see other things
happening and you're like when is cbs
gonna speak out when is
the survivor gonna speak out and they
finally did so
um that's a long-winded way of answering
your question but
it's it's always good from my
perspective it's always good to be able
to talk to jeff
because he is a good listener and he
then takes action
mm-hmm and jatia you mentioned the fact
uh it's not just about
in front of this the camera it's behind
the scenes the actual voice behind the
scenes and the importance of that
what was that conversation like saying
were you going for it and saying we
should have fifty percent by pack behind
the scenes as well
so so we detailed our concerns
and we specifically talked about what we
wanted to see
behind the scenes as far as support
staff and decision makers
so we were pleasantly surprised when
they came back with ideas specifically
about survivor
um we've yet to see them implemented and
we are optimistic that they will be
but in casting in support like
psychologists and in crew
so we don't have any insight into their
numbers and
of course we're not officially a part of
survivor anymore
um but we have thought they were great
ideas and we look forward to it we were
glad that they heard us
and actually took some of our ideas and
came up with some of their own as well
and 8 000 signatures i believe is that
or is it still
more than that now in terms of growing
like
that must mean so much to you
i think that is great so we started this
effort and we really didn't know
where we were gonna go um the name soul
survivor was
what we were calling ourselves for our
black survivor reunion
and then it just grew into this really
organic
group of people who all had a common
vision of taking our message to the
public
we've been talking about how we didn't
think that african americans were
portrayed well
on survivor for a long time and we felt
like
now was the time to take our ideas and
put them into action
so we came together as the soul survivor
organization
and we put together kind of a
three-prong we had the petition
we also had uh public affairs going down
on social media
and talking to news outlet like et
canada
and then we also put together
a group of survivors to talk about their
specific issues in panels
so we really had an organized attack it
was so great to work
with my fellow organization members i
got to know window a little bit better
also jamal shipman bryce isaiah and so
it's really make me feel more a part
of the survivor community doing this
effort so it's a win all the way around
it's a win for diversity and it's a win
for us former survivors
you say you got to know wendell i'm like
is he kind of cool or is he oh um
between me he's a little weird
just a little right yeah yeah i'm very
weird
so i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you what i
told wendell um
and i hope he doesn't get upset with me
but i said wendell you know you're a
little weird i was like
you are an ivy league lawyer turned
woodworking genius i was like this is
out of like a tyler perry movie you're
like the lead
love interest in the tyler perry movie
no comment see it is funny
too now that i'm like all off my rocker
but if i can go back
no if i could go back to what jatia just
said i think what was so cool about this
is that it really was a holistic effort
um
by a lot of us a lot of the black
castaways came together
and we all had um kind of like we all
had these messages
but we all wanted the same end we all
wanted to be portrayed better we wanted
more representation etc etc etc
we wanted a better storytelling from our
perspective
and with all of our voices including
julia carter
and many others um this this
this beautiful thing came together and
we were able to kind of
give something to cbs for them to really
digest and act on
and it showed i i think it showed the
power of us as a collective
and um that's something that i i was
very impressed by
you know one of the changes that we did
see this season with big brother
was all-stars was devon she came onto
the show
she spoke her truth and there was a
platform where people were actually
listening i mean they didn't cut it
they let her run they let the emotions
run i mean that itself says a lot
and she comes out of being what
america's favorite house guest at the
end of the day
i mean ever i think right right yes yes
and
and that was an awe moment when you
watch the show you're like
whoa cbs is actually going there
i mean that's a big deal too when you
give people
the um i i think when you allow
um minorities or you know if you
when you allow bypoc members of society
to go on tv
and be fairly represented um and speak
their voice and speak their truth
i think it's a win not just for
minorities but it's a win for america
and i think that was shown in um devon's
reception on big brother for sure
so i definitely have something to add to
this um first of all i want to give a
shout out to the hardest working
demographic
in america the black woman this has
really been
the summer where black women saved i
feel like
america so starting with beyonce
she released black as king and then we
had wap
taking back our sexuality it's black one
and then we bam we hit him with
carmilla so i just feel like black women
are killing it and i am so proud of
devon included bailey i just feel like
we're really making strides
i am so proud to be a black woman and to
just really be
a part of american making us the best
nation
because of black women and their efforts
and to just do the damn thing
no beautifully said you know so one of
the things
and it was a discussion that i had and i
was listening to a podcast
and um when you look at the faces of any
television show there's always that
tokenism right
and one of the things i hear is that
there's not enough
bypoc people of color actually wanting
to do a show
that they don't actually want to do this
and i'm like
that doesn't make sense to me so how do
you reach that fifty percent bypass how
do you reach that moment how do you get
it out there saying
you can actually apply i think first of
all you have to do better
like nobody wants to apply to a show
that um
consistently takes people like you and
makes them look like fools
so that's one thing and then also you
have to you can't just sit back and say
i want you to come to me
if you want that diversity you have to
go to where they are
so you need to go whole open casting
calls where there are african-american
people
i tell you i live in chicago if you go
to the south side of chicago for a
casting for survivor believe me it'll be
a lot of black people and you'll get
some really good footage too i'll tell
you that
and a big moment for us here at big
brother canada erisa cox who
uh not only is a host but now she is an
executive producer which is
beyond uh and she is all about 50
by pog i mean when you heard that news
knowing that change is happening and
here we are talking about cvs doing the
same thing
that's a big deal too it was the
greatest feeling when
when i saw that announcement um i i
i'm friendly with erisa and i texted her
i was so proud of her
and when i when i heard that i was just
like i was over the moon
i continue to text her saying how proud
i am but also how proud we are
because this like we look to her we look
up to her
and for her to have this um this job
where she can really
effectuate change and where she is
very vocal about how she wants to do
things it's it's
yeah it's the best feeling as someone
that really looks to her as like a
mentor
and as as just a wonderful leader in the
community
so erisa is somebody that i also got to
know through this process i basically
told her we were going to be friends
which is how i make all my friends
um i'm waiting on you girl
so anytime girl i'm ready you know
you're on my list
um so she is fantastic she
um i spoke with her quite a few times
during this process and she always had a
positive word
and encouragement about where we were
going and really her
idea was the blueprint i mean really
could cbs come back with anything less
than 50
if arisa cox i mean if arista cox is
doing it hello
that is what needs to be done so major
props to her and she's gorgeous and her
hair moves with the breeze
she's a gorgeous woman inside and out
now would you ever
let's just say survivor was looking for
an ep
would you consider it
yes yes sorry yes jake
so silencer was like wait a minute wait
without question in that position you
you're a gatekeeper then and we need
we need that kind of representation and
that's something that we're looking for
and i am hoping to see
a executive producer of color um on
survivor sometime soon so
you know erisa cox did it we're putting
it out there right we yeah
i think to that that's probably the next
step you need someone on the top tier
level that is
able to make those changes happen all
the way down what can we do to help you
to continue this fight so
this fight definitely will continue uh
me personally i plan to await the new
season of survivor i'm so excited i
can't even get it out
um and really just watch and tell them
what i think give them feedback
again like wendell was saying jeff's the
listener so
we put our messages together and we
present them in a manner
um that they can digest and i think they
will respond so if we need to we're
watching
and we're ready to gear up whenever we
need to
i think uh continuing to elevate our
voices
um et canada has been a great platform
always for um reaching out to us and
sharing our message and we appreciate
that i know i appreciate my
canadian fans and my canadian cousins
that are in toronto
i i love the north so we're so thankful
that
um it's like almost this this whole
country is able to amplify our voices
and if we continue to use our voices and
speak strong and speak the truth
and when there are great media outlets
that are willing
to put us out there and share our voice
it just
it makes it allows the world to hear us
a lot louder so
we thank you we thank et canada and we
will we won't stop
talking and marching and speaking and
kneeling and doing everything that we
need to do on our end
and we're gonna just continue to
hopefully change the world
you